tout
[Musique]
bienvenue sur la face cachée de la lune
messieurs jim gardant des prières je
vous aime pas les noirs d'un honneur
d'être parmi autant d'encouragements
vous croyez que le nouveau patron nous
obligera à patrouiller les environs
chaque fois qu'on nous tirera dessus
chaque fois qu'ils tirent à l'aveuglette
sur nous ils voient notre réaction
quand les vrais méchants argent
nous connaîtrons parker
[Musique]
notre travail est de séparer les
talibans des citoyens ordinaires
tout ce que les américains semblent
c'est d'abord sur leur chemin je peux
vous donner de l'argent
des contrats des projets
si vous collaborez
[Musique]
on fait de grands progrès ici à cannes
dèche
mais beaucoup de travail reste à faire
notre avant postes
reste une cible pour les insurgés
comment faire votre travail est resté
sain et sauf
il se préparait
combien
plusieurs noms troc est
mbm ville aux périmètres
c'est trop dangereux fuyez brenneke
on va vous sortir de là 4 juin
cache toi
tout doit reprendre le corps
nous devons continuer de nous battre
tu n'as pas mourir
là sont les meilleurs amis tu te feras
jamais
c'est bien là la soirée compote c'est
refuser l'invitation la compote complot
brutus
cki césar pour toi selon terre or ça
suffit avec tuteur danois c'est pas
parce que j'ai mis ta mère enceinte que
je suis ton père antonia vous voulez
tuer c'est or il y à un endroit où il
est vulnérable
la carotide non c'est au sénat qu'il est
vulnérable plus qu'à la carotide
c'est toi brutus qui aura l'honneur de
frapper en premier jeu pour créer un
truc genre liberté c'est pas possible ça
tu le sens voulu
ton fils de rejoint l'ennemi
il semble très proche d'une go noir tu
vas tuer ce traître je te donne 2010 à
paris je vais donner ce que je peux en
tant qu'esclave ton cerveau est pas
adapté tu peux pas comprendre ce que je
dis pas franchement là j'ai tout compris
non non
[Musique]
elle te plaît al banna un peu wahou a
été touché et dégoûté aussi du fait d'un
point de vue gastrique c'est fou
[Applaudissements]
une teuf teuf
il me mélange le blanc et le rouge donc
est happé par les douze coups de fouet
bonjour la toge à moi j'ai jeté mes
chiens
[Musique]
radioscopie
si je me suis retrouvé au pied d'un même
clan ghana
[Musique]
je ne sais plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un moine joueurs sur la toile
photo
au départ du cross 25 ans
[Musique]
l'enfant mairie
font du sport
[Musique]
google a qu'un pas
nom de code
passoire qui perd
contact à billy boy arnold
d
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
nate whitling juste
chanteur
à suivre
[Musique]
où
si grosses valises pour une seule nuit
allez aurait dû être parti depuis plus
d'une demi heure il est hors de question
que tu aille les chercher
[Musique]
c'est idiot
il est derrière nous tu l'avais vu je
voudrais que tu redémarre l'espoir en
occuper je verrai ça
[Musique]
mais depuis nous
faut pas vous inquiéter ce type est
parti
[Musique]
des trucs de l'astronome on n'y comprend
rien allez viens
croyez vous
fait comme nous c'est compris
[Musique]
allez saute
kim est arrivé
je suis mort qui veut dire que tout ça
n'est qu'un rêve non des souvenirs
tous ceux qui sont dans le coma viennent
au même endroit
c'est à dire ici en commun certaines
personnes développent des capacités
uniques pour découvrir leur qualité les
gens ont besoin d'un coup de pouce
essayons de voir ce qui est rend si
particulier
j'étais sur le balcon ces chefs
et nous a appris à survivre ici
nous sommes là pour une raison tous les
gens présents n'avaient pas vraiment
réussi dans la réalité n'a pas encore
compris doumier règle doit c'est moi qui
ai tiré cesser
si ce monde est fait de souvenirs
moi ce qu'ils arrivent ici non attention
il ya une île dans coma où il n'y a pas
un seul fouchard on est toujours à la
recherche de ceux qui peuvent nous aider
à y aller
ma vie est ici maintenant
bien que je pouvais pas être avec celui
de gmail
et si oui
ce monde n'a jamais été capable de
mettre en valeur les projets originaux
et insolites
pourquoi aurait-on besoin de la réalité
après ça faut qu'on se réveille
pat réveiller tu comprends
ton corps est ici à caux maturité
3 rien n'est changé d'avis dans le coma
est tout aussi réel
et lance là
[Musique]